bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
allez on continue notre tour de la
réunion aujourd'hui on est à matouta
alors si vous connaissez pas pas de
panique non plus dans ce matin je
n'avais jamais entendu parler de ce
village alors c'est un tout petit
village vraiment hors du temps situe à
300 mètres d'altitude où s'est installée
la famille des prêts 10 couverts ici une
ferme auberge
je suis censée retrouver oui leaf qui
doit être quelque part dans le champ de
palmiste ici pour aller lui file un coup
de main allez c'est parti
j'entends le bruit du gac en train
d'affûter son couple
aulas oublie celle aventure pour me
retrouver
bonjour et oui chez nous en plus
aujourd'hui on a un peu de soleil donc
c'est à dire ça fait plaisir que et donc
du coup ça c'est ton champ de palmiste
c'est mon champ de palmiste et partie du
champ de palmiste et la ferme auberge
elle est où la sphère engage à 800
mètres juste derrière toi juste rentré
du village de matous temps exactement
et là on est là pour quoi du coup de feu
dans la liste j'ai sélectionné de
palmiste qui sont très très beau là on
n'a pas le mr rouge
il faut savoir qu'il existe une
multitude de pamiers donc ce palmistes
là c'est un palmistes endémique à la
réunion et il est excellent et ça se
passe comment du coup pour la croissance
faut compter combien de temps à voir
d'avoir un palmistes de ce gabarit là
par exemple comme celui là ouais il a
plus de dix ans plus de dix ans celui-là
ouais ah ouais quand même à palmistes
pour pouvoir l'utiliser c'est entre cinq
et dix ans donc en dessous il ya des
gens qui peuvent le coupé mais ça c'est
très petit et nous on attend quand même
d'avoir d'avoir de la matière pour
pouvoir l'utiliser
à quel niveau des calculs coeur
finalement la partie sombre juste avant
le payage sont importants de la campagne
ont encore un peu
ouais et c'est sur une longueur de 30 cm
ah oui trente centimètres la partie
qu'on utilise pour la salade s'est
vraiment passé un c'est minime par
rapport à l'arbre jeu mais c'est ça
parce que finalement tu dis qu'il faut
dix ans de croissance pour faire pousser
le palmiste pour finalement récupéré le
coeur qui lui l'a pas grand-chose à 102
cm
il est
j'imagine que tu te poses pas tous les
clients ont enlevé un tollé les
enveloppes voilà donc tu vois comme ça
blanchi ça veut dire qu'on va se
rapprocher de la partie comestible
d'accord c'est beaucoup plus facile à
couper alors par contre là pour éviter
de gâcher
dis moi tu coupes vraiment ici vraiment
à la base du plan clair voilà hockey ah
oui effectivement c'est un peu plus tard
ah oui c'est super tendres comme vous le
voyez des gens viennent tout juste de le
couper ça a déjà commencé à s'oxyder oui
effectivement ça doit aussi sa deuxième
marron voir virer vers le noir
au bout de cinq minutes et c'est quoi du
coup tu as technique toit pour le 1 pour
éviter que ça se décide
il faut immédiatement l'assaisonner
le
bref ça y est ça ma petite activité
sportive du matin je repars avec mon
palmistes et puis on va essayer d'en
savoir un peu plus sur la préparation
non
donc avant de passer à la préparation du
repas on a décidé d'aller faire un petit
tour à matouta au village est
définitivement un joli coin de réunion
un village plein de charme qui veulent
des toits et là on est du coup bas pour
nous à la sortie du village à la ferme
auberge des prairies et là je sens déjà
les bonnes et flux qui s'échappe de la
cuisine où je vais leur rejoindra oublie
donc ils m'ont dit un petit peu plus sur
la préparation du fameux palmistes
bonjour me lis ça va village en vraiment
sympathique ça donne envie de venir se
poser si pour un week-end et super aussi
pas petite ferme auberge elle a du champ
petites structures familiales
on a équipé la maison la partie
restauration et chambre comme on pouvait
parce qu'il faut préciser qu'on fait là
on est vraiment sur la partie aux biens
mais en fait la partie interne sur la
800 mètres plus bas
ça c'est la cuisine c'est la cuisine ou
masseurs vois que tu as ramené les deux
palmiste rouge qu'on a qu'on a récupéré
tout à l'heure à force de transpiration
que nous laisserons de côté pour pouvoir
l'utiliser donc pour notre petite sirène
2010 tout en sachant que la salle de
palmiste se prépare à la dernière minute
d'accord on va pas financer tout de
suite la préparation du comice va mettre
non non pour ce midi on a des pieds port
donc pas de logement que chokri
baccouche rien car ils pouvaient pays
wallon total à démarrer excuse moi mais
c'est un grand vide et hitman comme sa
sortie du jardin je pense que non mais
attends il ya du cari après un oui est
ce que je peux pas tout manger que
j'appréciais j'apprécie tient
effectivement très con le caméraman
ambühl ah bah non
bah pas de bouche pas de balade
et donc du coup vous c'est la maman
n'aucune enchanté donc une véritable
entreprise familiale
donc si j'ai bien compris willy lui
s'occupe du champ liliane elle s'occupe
des caries et vous là dedans
oui un petit peu tout et les chambres
aussi mais peut-être pas les faits un
échange mais pas à montrer les chambres
écoutez regardez je vous prends cela ça
c'est pour faire un billet de shaw a
baigné de chou d'accord bah alors c'est
comme vous voulez soit on fait le
beignet de shu sont à faire l'échangé
mais nier c'est tout à l'heure en valeur
les chambres
la mamie aucune erreur
et donc je vous avez combien de chambre
et sénat six chambres six chambres
ça va c'est pas trop compliqué
l'entretien ça va et les enfants qui
sont là c'est un plaisir les mêmes des
lits pour bébés voilà ma chance et vous
est ouvert toute l'année whitla nous
prendre des chambres toutes les
innovations est aussi d'accord moi est
parti en vacances et enfin la sympathie
et là c'est ça qui pratique on travaille
en famille
si on a toujours une personne pour
disputer le match acteurs vata si c'est
pas moi c'est louis julian s'il est
validé ainsi olivier mais n'a toujours
pas tout seul la compagnie mes amis avec
regret
je vois que j'arrive au bon moment pour
le palmiste et oui ça y est c'est parti
on est international
alors ça c'est quoi cette partie active
et me découper la non c'est la partie
qu'on appelle le chou parti qui est
aussi très bonne ouais mais comment
utiliser qu on va privilégier surtout
pour les gratins elle a cette
particularité de s'oxyder et d'oxydés le
reste du palmiste donc on n'utilise pas
de la salade là on va faire une salade
une bonne salade de famille s'est fait
avec cette partie là on accède partie là
qui vient là dessus donc on n'utilise
pas et admettons je veux faire par
exemple un port au port aux palmiers
sache le médoc a bien sûr donc quand
c'est cuit quand je suis épuisé le chou
que cette partie là et qu'on mange cru
on préfère garder le coeur lui même
exactement
alors tu la saison comment le solde de
base citron c'est beaucoup donc
effectivement le palmiste coeur d'êta
cuisine on à la salade qu'on est en
train de préparer et tu me parlais d'un
roulé de palmiste oui le feuilleté de
palmiste remington vous voulez de
palmiste ça c'est notre spécialité
ouais donc d'ailleurs j'en ai préparé un
logique pour vous puissiez goûter ces
adorables et il est
composé d'une pâte feuilletée dans
lequel je mets des brèves de songes avec
l'accord de fanny qui était au préalable
puis au milieu
tu dis là nous avons très bien ce qu'il
faisait pouvoir arriver au bout donc tu
mets bien dans un coin parce que j'ai
d'autres choses à mettre dedans je passe
une rencontre mais ils avaient 10 ans a
poussé on l'a abattu ce matin et c'est
moi qui ai fini par le mettre dans
l'assiette c'est la pression à ses
intérêts la dette jaudy alors donc là
nous avons une pitié une petite terrine
de foie de volaille
bon c'est pas du foie gras mais presque
on a sélectionné les plus beaux fois
qu'on avait qu'on a épicé et là nous
avons donc le feuilleter famille ce que
j'ai déjà découpé
on va vous voyez ça c'est l'aspect
familial tout le monde aide et ben moi
aussi je vais mettre la main à la pâte
quand même des sceaux
mais
donc on vient de finir le repas
liliane a définitivement réussi à me
réconcilier avec les caries pas de
cochon et là on se trouve je sais pas où
est ce qu'on se trouve précisément là on
est sur le bon l'unique pont de matouta
donc celui qui fait le relais entre la
commune de saint philippe et la commune
de saint-joseph est juste de l'autre
côté on a quoi la cena
on a accès à la forêt la forêt de
basse-vallée la valeureuse nom qui est
très très belle ouais elle donc quitte à
proximité matouta sympa en tout cas la
vue donc la ravine de basse-vallée juste
à côté le bassin où quand on était
petits on venait se baigner avec les
copains j'aimerais bien savoir un petit
peu plus sur toi sur ce qui t'a amené à
voir cette ferme auberge sens que tu
faisais avant avant j'étais commerçant
et disons que la cuisine en elle-même
c'est un peu l'idée de maman c'est à
dire que c'était le bâtiment aujourd'hui
qui est l'auberge
à l'époque c'était un commerce à la
glace des chambres à la place des
chambres
on avait une petite épicerie
d'alimentation générale après avec
l'arrivée des supermarchés
ça s'est décliné jusqu'à ce qu'on décide
d'arrêter je crois que c'était vers 96
je te remercie pour cet accueil merci
pour m'avoir fait découvrir ne serait-ce
que ce pont que moi je qualifie d'
emblématiques ou tout du moins
d'insolite merci beaucoup à tous il est
là très bientôt la vie des enfants mais
à campana d'aider les ans par la peña
bloqués à temps en catimini en vie c'est
donc à côté d'une école du village de ma
tout à moi je vais d'abord mettre un
gros plus sur l'aspect culinaire en fait
de la ferme auberge des pyrénées c'est à
dire que le fait de pouvoir manger un
palm isc été récupérés le matin rappelez
vous qu'à mais quand même dix ans a
poussé qui a été coupé avec amour par
les soins de willy puisse arriver dans
une délicieuse salade
c'est un véritable plaisir et je voulais
finir quand même sur une petite anecdote
la petite boîte à livres
le concept est assez simple ça marche
sur la confiance c'est à dire que quand
vous avez fini un livre vous venez le
déposer vous pouvez en prendre un autre
choix un petit plus aussi pour pour le
concept qui serait bon d'exporter un peu
partout aller en ce qui nous concerne on
se retrouve très bientôt sur les rôles
de lier de la réunion a plus